Eu adoro cinema!
Adoro, como foi dito, tudo
o que tenha a ver com som,
imagem, tecnologia, todas essas coisas.
E, mais ou menos há cerca de dez anos,
eu apercebi-me que,
dos filmes todos,
dos efeitos especiais que via no cinema,
a maior parte — os mais interessantes —
utilizavam uma técnica
chamada sistemas de partículas.
O que é que são isso
de sistemas de partículas?
Na realidade, é uma técnica
usada em computação gráfica,
em que se criam milhares,
ou até mesmo milhões, de pequenos pontos
e que, depois, todos estes pontos juntos
criam a ilusão de coisas como fogo, fumo,
pó, tempestades de areia, chuva,
pó de fada, todas essas coisas.
Por exemplo, imaginem,
esta explosão que podia aparecer
em qualquer filme de Hollywood.
Na realidade, esta técnica diz que
cada grão de pó
que vocês veem ali de fumo,
tudo isto são milhares
ou milhões de pontos.
Na altura, quando eu me apercebi disto,
como sempre tive uma paixão muito grande
pela área do som,
pensei: não seria fantástico
se nós utilizássemos isto para criar som?
Milhares de sons, de forma a criar
a ilusão de algo fantástico.
Mas foi só uma ideia
como aquelas 500 mil ideias
que temos ao longo da vida
e não fazemos nada para as concretizar
e o tempo foi passando.
Há cerca de quatro anos atrás,
mais coisa menos coisa,
eu tinha acabado o doutoramento
e ainda ninguém tinha pegado propriamente
nesta ideia de utilizar
sistemas de partículas para som.
Como cromo informático que sou
— porque esta cara não engana ninguém...
(Risos)
resolvi começar a escrever
o meu próprio código
e começar a criar o meu simulador
de sistemas de partículas para som.
Assim uma... "uau"!
E assim foi.
Comecei a programar em tempos livres,
a fazer algum código
e 70 mil linhas de código mais tarde,
tinha o meu simulador de partículas
que vocês veem aqui,
em que cada um dos pontinhos ali a mexer
corresponde a um som diferente,
em movimento.
Mas, para que serve isto tudo?
Sim, é muito bonitinho,
tem coisas engraçadas,
mas para que serve?
Da mesma forma que,
ao nível da computação gráfica,
nós não queremos que o animador
tenha que animar cada gota de água
ou cada grão de pó,
ou algo do género,
e criamos estas partículas
para que o computador crie estes pontos
e que trate desse trabalho todo,
a ideia é aplicar o mesmo ao som.
Ou seja, hoje em dia,
se estiver a trabalhar
numa grande produção
— imaginem um filme
que tem uma batalha épica —
o que vai acontecer é:
vai haver um "sound designer"
ou um "sound effects editor"
que vai querer recriar o som da batalha.
Agarrando na sua biblioteca de sons,
onde tem milhares de sons
dos mais diversos tipos,
vai buscar uma explosão aqui,
outra explosão ali,
umas metralhadoras aqui,
uns tiros ali, uns gritos ali,
a explosão que ainda agora soou aqui
passados 30 segundos vai soar ali,
e vai fazer tudo isto.
E, se for uma grande produção,
em que haja dinheiro e tempo,
provavelmente, o "sound designer"
pode passar, se calhar, uma semana
a trabalhar em tudo isto
e, talvez, juntar 20 sons em simultâneo
para recriar o som de uma batalha épica
com milhares de guerreiros a lutar.
A vantagem do software é que
eu posso agarrar nele e dizer:
eu quero criar dez mil sons
ou cem mil sons,
espalhados por um quilómetro quadrado.
Posso ir à minha biblioteca de sons
buscar 300 sons de guerra que tenha lá
para servir como base da minha simulação
e o software criar, então,
toda esta batalha,
não com cem, mas com cem mil ou dez mil
e, desta forma,
ter algo muito mais realista,
muito mais orgânico
e em muito menos tempo.
Como tal, poder criar, por exemplo, sons
como uma cidade no século XXV.
(Som futurista)
Ou um icebergue a partir-se.
(Som de icebergue a partir)
Ou o som de uma batalha aérea
na II Guerra Mundial.
(Som de aviões)
Tudo isto de uma forma
muito mais rápida e mais eficiente.
Mas, convenhamos.
Qual é a probabilidade de este software...
Embora ele possa ser utilizado
em pequenas produções,
a grande mais-valia dele é poder ser usado
em grandes cenas e filmes épicos.
Mas qual é a probabilidade
de um estúdio de Hollywood,
que esteja de volta de uma superprodução,
ir utilizar um software
criado num país longínquo,
de um indivíduo que mora
numa cidade desconhecida.
Convenhamos,
a probabilidade é muito, muito baixa.
Mas eu acho que, às vezes na vida,
temos de ser um bocado ingénuos,
ou um bocado convencidos
— depende do ponto de vista —
e achar que, se nós fizermos algo,
haverá alguém que vai dar valor
e que poderá utilizar
o fruto do nosso trabalho.
E assim foi.
Continuei a trabalhar, sem saber
se havia estúdios interessados.
Sem saber se alguma vez,
alguém que batesse com a cabeça na parede
se lembrasse de usar o software.
Acreditei e continuei a trabalhar.
Há cerca de ano e meio,
mais coisa menos coisa,
ia haver uma conferência em Los Angeles,
uma conferência de áudio
em que eu ia participar.
E algumas semanas antes de eu ir,
resolvi mandar meia dúzia de e-mails
para estúdios de Hollywood,
para pessoas que eu não conhecia
— que, garantidamente, não me conheciam
a mim de lado nenhum!
Na prática, o que dizia no e-mail era:
"Estou a trabalhar nesta área,
"é uma tecnologia que pode ser interessante
para grandes produções.
"Daqui a algumas semanas
vou estar na vizinhança.
"Se estiverem interessados em saber mais,
digam-me qualquer coisa."
Eu tive a sorte de, rapidamente,
ter tido algumas respostas.
Um dos primeiros estúdios
que me respondeu foi o Skywalker Sound,
a empresa de som criada por George Lucas
aquando da Guerra das Estrelas
e que, provavelmente, hoje em dia
é o maior estúdio
de pós-produção áudio para cinema,
que me convidou a ir dar uma palestra
às instalações deles, no Skywalker Ranch,
que ficam ligeiramente a Norte
de São Francisco.
Nos meses seguintes,
acabei por dar palestras
nos vários estúdios de Hollywood:
Universal, Warner Brothers,
Paramount Pictures, Sony Pictures,
Fox, Pixar, Pinewood Studios em Londres,
entre outros.
Como podem imaginar,
para alguém que adora cinema,
ir a estes sítios,
conhecer os bastidores dos estúdios,
conhecer algumas pessoas, algumas lendas
que já conhecia de ver os "making-of's"
— que gente croma vê —
(Risos)
É fantástico ir lá, conhecer lendas.
Por exemplo, o Ben Burtt,
que criou os sons da Guerra das Estrelas,
ou então o Mark Mangini,
que é daquelas pessoas que,
em dois minutos, faz-nos sentir
como se nos conhecesse a vida toda.
Para vocês terem uma ideia,
o Mark Mangini ganhou o Óscar este ano
com o filme Mad Max
e mandei um e-mail a dizer:
"Parabéns pelo Óscar!"
E ele: "Eu estava tão nervoso,
"estava numa pilha de nervos!"
(Risos)
O fantástico é que
nós estamos sempre à espera de Hollywood
como uma comunidade muito fechada,
os egos, as estrelas,
aquelas coisas todas...
Sim, há pequenos pormenores
em que vemos
que não é tão aberta quanto isso.
Só para entrar nos estúdios
há controlo de passaportes,
detetor de metais, o nome tem de estar
na lista de pessoas autorizadas,
essas coisas todas.
Mas, na realidade, vamos encontrar
pessoas extremamente fantásticas,
fora de série, muito simpáticas
e que estão lá porque querem
saber mais sobre o nosso trabalho
e é algo verdadeiramente fantástico,
podemos ver que não há egos,
não há grandes dificuldades
porque alguém vem de um sítio qualquer
"que nunca ouvi falar".
Isto é fantástico!
Hoje em dia, o software está a ser testado
em todos estes estúdios.
Já começaram a sair alguns filmes.
Um dos últimos filmes a ser lançado
e que utilizou o software
foi, precisamente, o Batman vs Superman.
Para além disso, houve outros filmes
que utilizaram o software,
o Steve Jobs, entre outros.
Para terminar, só três pequenas notas
que eu acho que são importantes.
A primeira nota é: usem as vossas paixões.
Ou seja, juntem os vossos "hobbies"
com o vosso lado profissional.
Utilizem a vossa paixão,
que é um combustível fantástico,
para o vosso trabalho.
A segunda é: apontem para as estrelas!
Sonhem alto!
Acreditem, não tenham medo de sonhar.
Convenhamos, uma vida sem sonhos
é uma vida um pouco sem sal.
Em terceiro lugar: trabalhem
para chegar aos vossos sonhos!
Porque, acima de tudo, os sonhos
dependem, essencialmente, de vocês.
Trabalhem.
Sim, há más notícias:
é preciso trabalhar muito
para realizar os sonhos.
As boas notícias é que
os sonhos dependem...
Existem vários fatores,
mas acima de tudo,
o fator número um é o vosso trabalho.
Se vocês trabalharem
para realizarem os vossos sonhos,
garantidamente, vão ter
boas probabilidades de lá chegar.
Por isso, juntando estas três coisas,
se vocês juntarem as vossas paixões,
os vossos sonhos e o vosso trabalho,
tudo junto,
não só vão poder dar
o melhor que têm para dar,
mas, para além disso,
vão ser muito mais felizes!
Obrigado!
(Aplausos)